ho ho ho Merry
Christmas and Happy New Year from Santa
Claus and what's a great uh present for
everybody in the
family is the tickets to a Tim Dylan
show maybe in Brea California Columbus
Ohio Bethlehem Pennsylvania Washington
DC Northfield Ohio San Antonio Texas
Dallas Texas Atlanta Georgia St Louis
Missouri Indianapolis Indiana Boston
Massachusetts let Connecticut which is
the Foxwoods Casino Chicago Illinois
Dana Beach Florida Phoenix Arizona
Atlantic City New
Jersey you can go to Tim Dillan
comedy.com and see Tim Dylan Live and
he's a good man I'm Santa Claus he's
never done anything wrong he's gotten
presents from me every year so I'm
telling you to go and see him this is a
paid advertisement I am being paid by
Tim Dylan to say this he's a prick
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dylan show it is Christmas and we are so
happy to be here for the final episode
of the year um and uh we are grateful
and this will not be a good episode to
listen to because you're not going to
really hear uh anything and I'm not
gonna you know this is going to be very
difficult for me to speak um although I
am I guess I'm managing it now I have a
a
beard uh celebrating Santa Claus
celebrating old St Nick let's see how I
look does it look
okay yeah this is good your nose is kind
of gone my nose is gone but that's okay
that's okay Santa Santa would Santa if
Santa were alive today would he support
what's going on in Gaza or would he not
that's the question but thank God he's
dead thank God Santa's dead so he
doesn't have to see what is happening
right now in the world mhm he doesn't
have to face the
nightmare that other people do Santa
Claus doesn't have to wake up and read
that Matthew Perry died from a ketamine
overdose in his hot
tub Santa doesn't have to read that with
Miss Claus while they have breakfast
they have
um I don't know what they'd eat for
breakfast a porridge or a an oatmeal but
Santa doesn't have to say ho ho ho get
me some oatmeal how did Matthew Perry
die oh it was ketamine overdose in his
hot tub Miss
Claus and then Miss Claus goes well a
lot of the elves have been going for
that ketamine
therapy to kind of relive their past
traumas and try to get to the other side
of them and he goes well I well that
just seems like they're using
drugs Matthew per died in his hot tub
from
ketamine and Santa doesn't have to live
it cuz he's he's
gone there is no Santa Claus and if
there was he'd be a guest at what's
going on right
now he would have assumed much like I
did that because Matthew pered had a
drug addiction for a very long time and
it ate away a lot of his liver I think
he was doing like 46 Viking in a
day that's what I thought it was I just
thought it was just one of those
things unfortunately it's not one of
those things it was a ketamine
overdose in his hot
tub which sucks well vicadin he was
using vicadin he was taking up to
55 vicadin a
day and that does a number on your
liver that's what I thought it was but
it was an overdose of
ketamine ketamine is the new it drug in
Hollywood like
OIC OIC is the shot you take to make you
less
fat ketamine is something
else it's a drug which I used to do when
I was doing drugs we called It Special K
we did it with ecstasy which is now
called
Molly but it's a drug that is supposed
to realign the Pathways in your brain
and everyone here is always doing that
they're always realigning the Pathways
in their brain they're taking
iasa they're on ketamine all the time
this is everyone in
La that you speak to they go I have to
realign my
neural Pathways because reality is too
Bleak that's really what it comes they
go I
can't deal with the reality of what's
going on I need my
brain see this is GNA be tough
beard breathing in
hair it's hard to breathe with the beard
on because I have a Santa beard on how
did I you know I used to do this you
know I was a I was a Santa who tried to
sign people up for Obamacare no way
years ago this is
true I was a
Santa little breathe on
my [__] God I have this cold sore
that's also why this kind of is nice to
have
I was a Santa who signed people up for
Obamacare I would go into bad
neighborhoods and I would sign uh poor
low-income people up for
Obamacare dressed as Santa Claus and it
was a job that I did and it was a job
that I did to supplement uh the money
while I was earning uh money to learn
how to be a stand-up
comedian and it was not a bad gig was
not a great gig because you would be in
bad areas and poor people are very
depressing around the the
holidays it's true they're they're
always getting shot or what I mean
they're just they're depressing people
over the holidays holidays are really
for you know it's really it's better to
have rich people or Rich family and
friends over the holidays because they
you
know holidays are for them you know like
the the poor people are always getting
shot or sick or they're working shifts
and they're complaining all the time and
that's not you know it's neither here
nor there but that's the job was tough
because they would always say you know
rich people around the holidays they're
just wearing coats and going to church
and having these feasts so when I was at
Santa in a poor neighborhood and I was
poor and everybody I'm talking to was
poor nobody's happy we're all
broke they're asking me questions about
health care I didn't sign up for Obama I
don't know I don't know what's going
on I'm just sitting in a truck dress to
Santa and they're they're telling me
about problems that they have I have
problem it wasn't it wasn't a good time
in my life but I can't even remember I'm
like how did I [__] do this with the
beard it's terrible it really irritates
you at one time and I told I talked
about this on the Pod there was I did it
at a Spanish chicken
restaurant I don't know what I where it
was it was on Long Island and there was
a big chicken and Dana mhm they had a
big chicken and everybody wanted photos
with me nobody wanted photos with the
chicken the chicken was dressed like a
chicken he was very upset about that he
was also signing up PE people for
ObamaCare what what the government
did to
get no but it's all true what the
government did to get lowincome people
on into Obamacare was they sent out like
like car characters whether it was like
me a Santa or a chicken or like the
Kool-Aid guy they sent them out into the
streets I'm not even kidding you can
look this up and it's probably not a bad
idea they sent like characters out into
the they sent out like
SpongeBob to try to get people to sign
up for ObamaCare
because you know people don't like
doctors right they get creeped out by
doctors they're creeped out by people
that are wearing suits but like if
Clifford the Big Red Dog or
SpongeBob or you know I don't know Paw
Patrol goes out and goes hey do you want
uh health insurance you might you might
be more amenable to
it I don't
know but there were that was like a
strategy that they
had back to Matthew Perry I gotta I
gotta take this be off I I it's the cold
sour is not that bad it's it's I I can't
deal with this hurting my face to a
point where I I can't even you know I
can't even deal with
it Matthew Perry RP very sad um we don't
we obviously do not uh we're not making
light of his
death you know but what here's what we
were saying about this k i me because
everybody's doing this
now and I you know as somebody who is a
ex addict I think maybe it's not a good
idea maybe it's not a good idea but
maybe it
is I don't know but a lot of people are
are are taking ketamine under the
supervision of a doctor they're going to
a clinic and I don't know I guess this
can help with PTSD
yeah you know for people that have come
back from
war but it seems to be abused people
seem to be abusing it like I know a lot
of people who do it and I go the last
thing you need to do is go and get shot
up with ketamine in a clinic you need
something else you don't need to do
ketamine in the
clinic that's not what it's for
iasa is not for you having a better
career that's not what it's for that's
not what the Incans intended that's not
what the Mayans whoever the f I don't
even care or
no the ancient cultures that used Iasi
as a spiritual experience were not
intending it to be used so that you
could figure out how to get on Netflix
there's no way there's no possible way
that's the intention of
iasa there's no way there's no way that
you were supposed to go into hyperspace
and ask the the aliens the entities or
for career advice there's no way it's
it's it's all
been completely
perverted by people that are in this
town want to just figure out how to make
life more about
themselves as if it's not already about
them they want to they want to make it
more about themselves
somehow somehow some way they go enough
of life it isn't about
me let me
really focus let me take three days let
me go to Peru let me
vomit and let me realize that all my
fears are just they're not real they're
holding me back and listen again this
would be great if the end goal wasn't to
you know snag a roll on jinny and
Georgia like if you were really evolving
as a human
being you would leave you would move you
would leave if iasco worked you'd come
back to
LA walk into your house Burn It Down
light it on fire and leave the state
forever if iasa were but whatever
professional grade Iowa and I don't know
who these shamans are these con
artists that are calling themselves
shamans people are drinking this stuff
all every three weeks they're on iasa
and they're more [__] than they've
ever been on
iasa I don't get
it and now people are dropping dead in
their hot tubs of ketam
everyone's like no it's good it's
rewires the neural Pathways in the brain
and because it's a lot to take it's a
lot to take when all of the big studios
go we want a a future uh without humans
we want a posthuman future it's a lot to
take people go [__] I got to take some
iasa to handle that I got to take a
little kenam me to handle that so that's
what the studios did they just said hey
I talked to some of these people
during this strike and they were very
clear about what they want they want a
posthuman future on Earth that's all
they want they're very clear about it
they want a
postum future on
Earth that's what they want that's what
they want they don't want human beings
anymore and that's tough to hear because
everybody's having the wrong fight
everybody's like you're paying me $30 I
want 35 it's like no no no no no no no
we don't want you to exist we want you
gone we want you out we want to do
things completely AI generated we don't
want you at all it's hard to hear it's
hard to hear that's why everybody's got
to go take iasa they got to do ketamine
one of these writers a guy The Hollywood
Reporter
went to do ketamine and flipped
out which is a kind It's Kind of a Funny
article MH when ketamine therapy visit
goes horribly
wrong so what this guy did and this guy
sounds kind of like a [__] who can't
handle his drugs now that doesn't mean
that this ketamine fad is good I know a
lot of people that are doing
this ain't not a one of them in a in a
place mentally that you should be ain't
not a one not a one of those people
walking around doing ketamine that I
know and the tens of dozens of people I
know do camine are are in a good uh
place all the
time I saw help from a cemine clinic
like Matthew Perry odd way to start it's
an interesting way to start the article
huh I sought help from a ketamine Clinic
like Matthew Perry things went wrong
what happened was the scariest
experience of my life here's what
happened the guy goes in the
room you know
listen to this I was probably always
going to get around to trying ketamine
therapy which I did two years
ago I had read all the things how the
animal tranquilizer and party drug can
work wonders for treatment resistant
depression how it can reset your brain
there it is again how ketamine's unique
disassociative effect allows the user to
take a step back get off their hamster
wheel of ego-driven thinking by the way
everyone I know on this stuff it's
they're the they're the most egomaniacal
people I've ever met in my life all of
the people on this by the way without
exception it's completely about their
all the time about them everybody I know
who does this stuff did never starts a
sentence with any other except I all of
them so I love this
idea that that it's you we're trying to
get rid of your ego with this in in La
that's where we're trying to get rid of
the ego is that why these people were
doing all of this because they're ego
they want to get rid of their ego no
they they want to help themselves get
more things
somehow they think this leads to them
getting more famous that's why they're
doing it because they want to get out of
their own way because people keep
telling them hey man everyone hates you
you come to the Christmas party drunk
you try to [__] someone's wife you're
not focused you suck and that's why
you're not succeeding you should do
ketamine and figure out why you act like
an [__] all the time so that's the
group of people that are doing this the
people are like yeah can you do camine
and stop trying to [__] my wife all the
time you
scumbag and they go I got to reset my
brain cuz everyone's telling them to
everyone's telling me I got to reset my
brain I have have to stop doing coke and
trying to rape children in La so they go
I'm I'm going to go get ketamine
treatment so listen I showed up for my
appointment filled out forms signed a
waiver and was ushered to a small dim
room with blinds on the
windows the room Center P centerpiece
was a cushy faux leather recliner that
faced an LED TV that was mounted high on
the wall next to the chair was an IV
stand the technician was a young woman
let's call her
Sarah it was unclear if she had any
medical credential credentials I'll stop
you there buddy she didn't
probably but she had this I'm just going
through the motion so do you want to
order any appetizers casualness made me
think not so she's basically the
ketamine waitress and so she gives him
ketamine and he goes I felt confused why
was I here again I started to feel like
I wasn't entirely in the room or was I
in the room and then I wasn't did you
give me the drug already so he he flips
out he has a bad uh trip if you want to
call it that he's uh doesn't know what's
going on it's unfortunate he gets uh
paranoid the room was gone I was gone
typically when you take a drug you
experience reality differently you feel
good or bad what you're seeing might not
be accurate but you were still you you
know this was different I was
unconscious technically but in a void
it's a khole it's khole I've been in a
khole I was 14 you're in a k you're
doing drugs what's wrong with these
people you're doing D
drugs these crazy people people are
taking crat them now like you you put
heroin in a smoothie it's heroin still
you're doing drugs they I I don't
understand what these people think's
going to happen because a nurse gives it
to you they killed Michael Jackson they
kill all of these people they will give
you anything you want if you have the
money they'll give you anything you want
they don't know if you need this therapy
or not they don't care
you're doing drugs and listen I'm not a
moralist in this regard I don't think
you should hurt other people but if you
get you know something out of this
positively great but it's a
drug people get to all kinds of Altered
States Of Consciousness all kinds of
ways fasting uh meditation all kinds of
other ways this is a shortcut you're
you're pulling up in a valley in a strip
mall you're sitting down
you're getting an IV while you're in a
lazy boy that's a shortcut to the
Altered States of reality you're trying
to get to it's a drug all these people
are like I had no idea what's going on I
just sat down and they shot me up with a
drug and then I was hi what's
that this was such a disassociative
state that I was disassociated from
everything that I ever knew existed I
was in space but not outer space What
horrible by the way what
horrible writing what terrible writing I
was in space but not outer space nothing
so neatly familiar as that there were
colors jungle greens and Browns well
that's what he doesn't like the Browns
jungle greens and Browns hey watch out
buddy I think the Drug's starting to
work you're getting a little honest all
these jungle people I didn't know what
was going
on there was that horrid noise that
blurring Matrix phone I had taken a fist
full of red pill it it's so bad the
writing this article is so terrible it's
so terrible I I I don't know if I even
believe this person did it I don't
know but this is
what my recurring thought was I'm dead
and this is Hell forever that's
everybody that has a bad triap it's so
cliche it's such a
cliche this is like anyone who read any
of those bad trip
reports and wrote about them
and just took this I was in that room
for about 90 minutes but that feels like
lying because I know I was in that void
for days see this is like a I don't even
know if this happened like I don't even
know if this happened or if this person
just took all these bad like trip
reports there used to be this website I
forget what it was called but it it was
it was a website and people used to
write about their experiences with drugs
don't look for it it doesn't matter um
people will know who are listening to
the show what it was and people would
write about their experiences with DMT
or other drugs and all of these are the
most cliche things to say and it might
that might be the case that they just
happen so frequently to people that they
all describe them the same way I don't I
don't know but this idea that like like
ketamine therapy is going to help all
the people that want it is crazy it's
crazy it's not true that it's there it's
a drug and it might work for you and
listen psychedelic therapies might be
good there's a lot of evidence that
these things are going to help right
military people I'm not discounting all
of this stuff I'm just going always the
only thing I can do is talk about
personal experience all I can do is talk
about the scores of people I know in Los
Angeles on these things and people claim
that they're uh there's been but then I
know a lot of these people and it
doesn't seem that
beneficial so then they they contacted
them they go you need more ketamine you
should come back you should come
back
and can anyone get this can I just go in
can anyone go in and get ketamine
therapy do you need a note from your
doctor do you need a note no you don't
need a note no you just I don't even
need a note I could just go in and get
ketamine shot up yeah khole yeah I could
just go do that yeah that's what we're
at uhuh
nice okay sure I mean listen people are
G to get mad at me for this this is when
I told people not to smoke pot in their
30s it was the most controversial
episode I ever did people were so angry
I said marijuana's for your teenage
years as you get older you should use it
very sparingly and people got so angry
with
me and they they they boiled over a rage
as people often do when I'm right which
I usually am and uh I feel the same way
about this [__] it's like
are the people that really are they
utilizing it in an appropriate way are
these PE are is
this is this being utilized in an
appropriate way or are a lot of people
going in there with no clue what's going
on and leaving with somehow less of a
clue of what's going on and listen I get
it people are happy cam mean it is a
therapy
and some people like it but it's you're
going into a
khaul
for
drugs it's what it is you're you're
disconnecting from the world with a
drug now maybe
it maybe it can treat other things and
it might be able
to but it's just fun there's
this it's not like the idea per se is
wrong it's the application of it the
application that anyone can just walk
into a room and do
ketamine uh and then as much as they
want and then follow their own plan
seems
stupid it seems pretty dumb ho ho
ho 35% of all fatal accidents occur
between 600 p.m. and
midnight I see them all in my
sleigh
people aged 25 to 34 have the highest
amount of drivers involved in car
crashes people aged 15 to 24 had the
highest rate of emergency room visits
due to car accidents of all age
groups if you're ever injured go to
Morgan and
Morgan it's a personal injury Law Firm
America's largest they have over a
hundred offices Nationwide and more than
800 lawyers with over $15 billion
recovered for over 3,000 300,000 clients
Morgan and Morgan has a proven track
record of fighting for all the good eles
and all the
reindeer Morgan and Morgan has been
fighting for the people for over 35
years submit an injury claim with Morgan
and Morgan it's so easy delivering
presence to all the boys and girls and
all the
others is hard submitting an injury
claim with Morgan and Morgan is
easy if you're ever injured you can
check out Morgan and Morgan their fee is
free unless they win for more
information go to for thee.
Tim or dial pound law pound 529 from
your cell phone that's forthepeople.com
Tim or pound law pound 529 from your
sell this is a paid advertisement ho ho
ho
Sue got a good night sleep is important
as Santa
Claus the night before the night before
Christmas I got to get sleep that's why
I do I use
Helix Helix is amazing take the quiz
they will figure out everything about
how you
sleep how to get you the best night of
rest you can
imagine Helix is all the beds in the
North Pole are Helix the little ones for
the
elves and one for me and even miss claw
has one in her separate room she kind of
occasionally goes in
there she doesn't like my snoring but
that's the way marriages work you know
you have to make uh sacrifices over long
periods of time and things like that we
still love each other other not the same
as it was of course but you know we're
kind of Partners in power it's kind of
that's that Dick Wolf book about the
clintons it kind of describes us as well
um I love these Helix beds they are firm
or soft or hot or cold or whatever you
want them to
be we're offering 20% off my listeners
orders Helix has already moved from a
three tier discount to 20% off for all
orders isn't that amazing
amazing it's
amazing individually wrapped steel coils
in the base with premium foam layers on
top it's a perfect combination of
comfort and
support Helix is offered 20% off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
o listers go to helixsleep.com
timd use code Helix
partner2 this is now the best offer yet
and it won't last long with Helix better
sleep starts next
now but you know what doesn't seem dumb
the
merger of Warner Brothers and
Paramount all of these companies in uh
in this space uh a lot of them have
merged uh Viacom merged with
CBS uh Warner BR um uh Warner Brothers
in Discovery merged Fox and Disney
merged and with all these they all want
each other's
assets they all want to make you know
these
massive conglomerates but what happens
after they all merge is that nobody
really
cares and they don't make any money this
isn't like a huge generator of cash flow
when these companies merge because
they're it's all dying
Industries I mean the streaming stuff is
one thing and that's clearly the future
but Cable's done people are cutting
cords no one's going back to cable TV no
one's ever going to go back to Cable
it's never going to go back all these
idiots that are like no we're actually
very we're actually pretty sure that the
people that watch will continue that no
one's going back ad spending is down
cords are being cut it's done over in
the casket six feet underground done
it's never coming back NE broadcast TV
is DOA
dead it's not coming back TGIF's not
coming back Boy Meets World's not coming
back
over so all of these companies they try
to bundle together all this
[__] like it's going to be better to
have a big heap of
[__] with some good nuggets some gold
nuggets in the [__] that people care
about but for the most part it's just
die it's dead and dying dead and dying
no one's going
back that's the thing it's like you're
never G No One's Gonna care about the
Academy Awards again ever no one's going
to care about the Emmy Awards again ever
no one's going to care no no red carpet
it's not coming back I don't care what
it doesn't matter in my neighborhood in
La these dumb little buses saw off the
tops and they drive people around and
point out what I don't even know what
they try to point out celebrities or
where the [__] they live no one cares
the only two people that people even
recognize in this town are those midgets
from the real estate show selling
Sunset and like Cruz you got to be the
biggest celebrity in the world or the
[__] from selling the real estate Show
on Netflix with those [__] those are
the only people that anyone realiz like
recognizes I've been in restaurants
where those midgets walk in and people
get really excited there are the
midgets that's what we got now it's
either Margot
Robbie Tom Cruz or the little
guys from the selling uh selling the
horor show selling wh the horse Selling
Houses whatever it is selling selling
[__] and the midgets those are the only
people that are recognized here no one
cares about any what of these people
when I pass these buses on the way to my
house it's always a confused Indian guy
sitting in the back he doesn't quite
know what's going on it's like a lovely
black couple from Tampa who are just
they're trying where's Jay-Z we know he
just bought where is where is the
Beyonce and Jay-Z they pray they're
asking the guy J he's like they're in
Malibu they bought something that looks
like a Community College Library are we
gonna see that on the tour we can it's
an hour away oh all right so they're
slightly disappointed that it's just a a
young kid with his family from Belgium
or something they don't know what the
hell's going on they're all in jackets
cuz it's cold and rainy here they were
sold this lie this bill of goods that
it's like uh pretty and it's always
beautiful and sunny and none of them
really know what they're doing there
they're all confused and they just point
they pointed you can't see any of the
houses they Point into this Canyon they
go and they just point into this void
it's actually very kind of poetic and
appropriate they pointed into a like in
New York when I was a tour guide we
pointed a building Chrysler
Building this is where they did hey
Ground Zero where they did the thing we
always had an exact point in La you just
point to a void a big canyon where
there's just big mansions all around and
you go Mark Walberg and the Indian guy
goes who that you go Mark Walberg oh yes
yes Mark Walberg and then he turns
around to his friend they nod but
there's nothing uh there's nothing left
there's there's nothing to see so all of
these mergers at the end of the day will
will they will
not stem the tide of the inevitable
destruction of the entire business the
entire business is over sorry to my
agents and managers who are lovely
people but the entire business is going
to end maybe not tomorrow but it is
already over it is already
dead someone made a good point the other
day Aquafina just doesn't have a black
scent
anymore we all knew she was a rapper
Aquafina had a black scent go see that
Asian movie uh the the rich Asian people
whatever that crazy Rich Asians it was
lovely I enjoyed it people didn't like
it but I liked
it the black scent is so severe in Crazy
Rich Asians that even a man such as
myself who does not get offended at such
things was like oh my God like there's a
scene where she's like B
[__] B [__] it's so late on so
thick but now she's just like hello I am
aw with him and she doesn't have a black
and we all supposed to forget that she
had a black this is why Hollywood
doesn't work anymore I'm not going to
live in a post Aquafina blacks scent
world that's not going to happen it's
not going to happen I won't do it I
refuse to do it I will not think of
Aquafina as someone that speaks normally
her whole thing was being like b b
[__] and now we we just pretended to
we pretend that it never happened it's
not coming back so they can merge all of
these things and it's big daddy zaz our
friend David zazo who just want and by
the way God loved this man all he wants
to do and people get so mad at this man
all he's trying to do is build a company
so big that no one really knows why it's
failing that's all these guys are
looking to they just want to build a
company that's so big that no one can
there's what they call a diffusion of
responsibility Google that diffusion of
responsibility what that means is that
no one really knows what's going
on nobody knows who to
blame diffusion of responsibility is a
sociopsychological
phenomenon whereby a person is less
likely to take responsibility for action
or inaction when other bystanders or
Witnesses are present considered a form
of attribution the individual assumes
that others either are responsible for
taking action or or have already done so
by making these companies as big as
humanly possible no one can really know
why they've all
failed it's just spe like you know the
Marvels failed that that movie they did
because I think people have had enough
finally finally after 15 years I think
adults in our country and maybe maybe
this is the good side of ketamine
therapy adults don't don't want to watch
people in costumes at the moment at the
moment they're not going out the way
they used to to see the Marvel movies
and you know I mean nobody just nobody
will tell you why it fit people well
it's co and when it was being made we
weren't really checking in on it and
then there's the economy and then
there's the it's a diffusion of
responsibility and this is what big
daddy zaz
wants let's make it so big let's get
Paramount Paramount plus get Yellowstone
we'll merge it with Warner Brothers
Warner Brothers is a little bigger than
Paramount but let's smash them together
let's make this [__] they know
the only way they're going to survive is
by being too big to fail because the the
it is written it is written in the
prophecy here we are it's done we know
that we know that and we know that the
only way to fight back is to create
these massive
behemoths that what what did the Banks
do what did the banks do by the way the
banks became so big that they could do
whatever they wanted and the government
had to keep bailing them out and the
bank what are you gonna tell cha you
gonna tell Chase they go [__] you so
what did a little insider trading so
what it doesn't matter pay the deal pay
the fine they pay the fine Goldman Sachs
and the and the treasury Department is a
revolving door they just go to Goldman
work for a little bit make a little
money buy a couple of houses and go to
the treasury Department and make laws
that are good for Goldman Sachs all
these other Hollywood companies like
yeah we get this we understand we need
the government on our side to allow us
to merge and create these very very big
institutions that are too big to fail we
can kind of do whatever we want we tell
everybody [__] off tell everybody [__]
off it's going to be so big and people
are going to go like oh my God a lot of
what they're making is terrible how are
they even in business I'm like because
they own it all they own it
all they just bought the Brooklyn Bridge
they're going to own everything NBC
Universal owns theme parks uh television
stations stream a movie studio like you
know they they make money all over the
place and they're not re they're not
relying on anyone's stream of red they
don't care if you don't watch the
thing they don't care they have theme
parks making money which will allow to
indulge the This creepy Obsession they
have with social justice they'll be able
to do emit till on Ice you know it'll
just be that's what they'll be able to
do and everyone will go well that
doesn't seem fun who's going to see EMT
till on Ice that seems odd that's not
holiday that's not at all that's not a
holiday icecapades you go no no no no
that's important that's important and
the reason that they're able to do emit
till on ice the the whole story is
because the company is so [__] big
that they'll put out a
Yellowstone every now and then or
they'll buy uh something else so that's
where it's at here everybody the only
way to survive is to get so big so big
and they're gonna fire people when they
merge which they might I don't know if
they will but that's what they want to
do they want to merge they want to get
rid of a lot of people and the company
is going to get bigger they're buy they
want assets they don't care about the
people
they just want the things they want the
mission impossible they want the things
you have you know they'll get all those
assets the people watch the people like
the people enjoy and then they get rid
of all the people they go get get out of
here get the get out of here
fired thank you we're so excited about
this murder now get the [__] out you
have till five o'clock Chuck look at me
you have till 5 o' today to clean out
your [__] desk and get out of here
you better go to the ketamine Lounge you
better go drive over to the ketamine
thing and get your head right reset your
head Chuck you're done we want Mission
Impossible we don't want Chuck at
Paramount we want Mission Impossible now
go get the ketamine
therapy that's what's going to happen
that's what's going to happen then and
and all the people that look at this and
operate as I do on the outside of this
are just we're just going to watch it
and observe it we're going to watch it
and observe it with a keen interest and
we go huh huh interesting and I know
people that work in these things will
chat occasionally about stuff and I
don't know if they think I'm wrong they
probably
don't they might
disagree at the end of Q3 powermount
Global reported long-term debt of 15.6
billion considerably less than Warner
Brothers whose debt load stood at 43
billion see that's the thing now we go
we ow 43 billion you ow 15 let's get
together getting this is why couples by
the the way with debt like people say
that's not good when a couple has debt
actually it's only if one person has
debt and the other person doesn't it
creates resentment if both people are
dirt bags as my parents were it works
fine it actually works better if both
people owe a lot of money they're able
to Sherk that responsibility together
it's actually a kind of nice life you're
dodging people all all the time together
you don't answer the phone you don't
open the mail you have a po. box if
possible so you can get present with
that deck collector you're you know
you're constantly anybody who just calls
your name in public even if it means
your table at Applebees is ready you
think they're a process server and they
serve you with a judgment but if two
people have debt it's actually nice
Discovery is the bigger fish with a
market cap of 28 billion par amount has
10.3 billion so they want let's merge
it on the flip side Warner Brothers
Discovery Big Daddy zaz would acquire
top tier properties from Paramount
Pictures like Terminator Transformers
Mission Impossible Top Gun a quiet place
Ninja Turtles to Godfather Paranormal
Activity scream Star Trek Warner
Brothers Warner Brothers uh pictures
stable includes the DC extended Universe
Harry Potter and the Lord of the Rings
they bring LED table as
well the other thing that's really
rattled the town is the Israel Gaza
Palestine question people are these
guilds The Writers Guild and sag people
got in these big fights at C and almost
lost her job UTA dropped Susan Sarandon
they fired the chick from Scream oh yeah
the uh thing it's it's it's you know
it's contentious out here Melissa
Barrera fired from Scream s then Jenna
Ortega left from Wednesday she left
scream I don't know why that was but
Jenna Ortega was you
know probably like hey man let me get
out of here this is getting hot this is
getting a little
hot so the inability it's it's harder
and harder
now to get people on the same page about
anything it's just difficult
there used to be a way to get people on
the same page and it was called sexual
black male and it really worked it
really really
worked you would photograph or videotape
people having sex with underage people
and then that would be used against them
that was really really an important
component of getting people on that was
how we built te team building it's a
team building exerc size isn't it we're
roll in it together team
building here's the file here's the
flash drive what do you think right
right right you're with us that's what
it used to be blackmail blackmail that's
how it was done people like how was it
how did it used to be done
blackmail that was
it that's true people were gay and
people said well pretend you're not
gay but you have to no matter what you
got to say exactly what we want you to
say or we're going to talk about you
sucking [__] you go oh [__] okay or you
were a pedo or you were a junkie go we
know you're a junkie we're g to tell
everyone you're a
junkie or you say what we want you to
say we drive the coke right to the
house which would you
rather what would you rather this would
have never h they would have never had a
[__] top tier actress popping off
rarely did that happen
rarely they had control it was it was a
town based on control was a system based
on control here's what you get you get
sex you get drugs you get you get all
these things you get money but you can't
you got to go along with the thing
whatever the thing is whatever the thing
happens to be it is what it is we'll
give it to you but you you got to go now
no one can control anybody else it's
chaos out here it's cha people are
popping off and saying
things not good they're saying things
that they feel they're going I I don't
know it's it it does seem like a lot of
civilians and people are like shut up
but they you can't get people to go you
can't put it back in the
Box this is why this town is over for
good good you can't put it back in the
Box
sociopathy isn't new and it's not rare
but for a while at least in California
it was a
topdown
paramilitary Structure where the people
who were let's say the biggest
sociopaths the Weinstein people like
that were able to control the smaller
less successful
sociopaths but see now we've raised an
entire generation of sociopaths who do
not need big papa sociopath we've raised
an entire group of people that believe
they should be famous all these kids on
the internet go I should be famous for
what who knows doesn't matter I should
be famous because we've raised them to
believe that Fame in and of itself had
value it wasn't about Talent it wasn't
about uh doing anything it wasn't about
the craft of anything it was about Fame
in and of itself Fame and money that's
what you should get fame fame leads to
Money Money leads to fame da d da so
they don't need these big institutions
anymore they can go out and do it
themselves they have the ingredients
they have their phone they have a
Macbook they don't
need the system the old system where
they would lock them up in a castle on
the hill and go we have the [__] and
the blow
you just have to say everything we want
you to say you can't deviate you cannot
deviate we're going to put you on a
Morning Show and we need you to say
whatever you got to stand next to
Hillary Clinton and clap awkwardly while
the 10,000 Maniacs play that song these
are days these are days
to that's what it was so there's no
coming back here and that doesn't you
know that that depresses people not me I
don't
care I don't care it's a good a town as
any to be destroyed there's nothing
wrong with that we need things to die in
order for things to live there's nothing
wrong with that either but this is why
it's happening and then the people that
are left here are on ketamine in a in a
in the valley they're sitting in a chair
being shot up with drugs or they're
going to Peru to drink iasa because they
cannot just admit that it's not coming
back it's not
jogan killed it he took him he killed
it my episode with him is out by the way
the Joe Rogan Experience if you want to
watch
that um there is
just there is a lot here to be thankful
for because it is the holiday this is
our final episode before the new year
there is a lot to be thankful for there
is truly a lot to be thankful
for
um we are entering a time of utter chaos
2024 is going to be one of the most
chaotic
years probably in the history it will be
the third election I'll cover on this
show I covered Trump covered Biden
covering maybe Trump again it's going to
be utter chaos um I don't think any of
us are quite ready for it it'll be very
interesting um to see how this takes
shape Colorado knocking Trump off the
ballot saying he cannot he's not
eligible to run other States like
California are looking into it now going
huh what are we gonna do and what's
making it all very interesting and this
kind of ties into what we talked about
before is
that everybody's off the leash now for
the most part not everybody I mean the
media is still beholden to their
paychecks
um but you can't you can't frame
anything anymore the way you could have
even even five years ago it's uh
everything is just out there and that's
not always you know good but we're just
heading into maybe the craziest
year that anyone of us can picture just
complete utter
Insanity across the
board China Taiwan Russia Ukraine Israel
Palestine the Biden family
Trump it's gonna get it's gonna get fun
and it might get
ugly um but the great the thing you can
be grateful for is that you're alive in
the moment that's what you should be
grateful for I know that it's not not a
huge thing but it is actually the only
thing and the only thing that you should
care about you're alive in the moment to
witness this whatever it kind of will be
a lot of people did not make
it you know to this RP to the lesbian
barbecue person that used to make me
brisket she's not here people leave
people
go but there are people that are still
here with us and you're one of them so
we appreciate that and I don't know
what's going to happen in 2024 I don't
it seems like it could spill over they
keep making movies by the way you know
Netflix just made this movie uh Leave
the World Behind and a24 is making this
Civil War movie it's like hey guys how
about making a movie about uh things
being okay how about that how about that
why don't you get out of your comfort
Zone and make a movie about things uh
that are
good it's so hack right now and I
enjoyed the Leave the World Behind but
as an overarching point it is so hack
right now to make a movie about Society
disintegrating yeah we get it we get it
we're watching it make something nice
make something nice
again make something about people that
love each other make something about a
country that's it's it's going to to
work stop making everything about people
killing each other we're we're getting
enough of that that's coming going to
see that enough escapism how about that
perhaps um we do appreciate you guys
we're on the road all the time and we do
uh appreciate you guys coming out we've
got some theater some fun comedy clubs
trying to get Clips hunting for Clips in
those comedy clubs um but we'll be a
Brea New Year's Columbus Bethlehem
Washington uh Ohio San Antonio Dallas
Atlanta St Louis Indianapolis Boston
Foxwoods Connecticut uh Chicago Danny
Beach Florida Phoenix Atlantic City Tim
comedy.com you can get tickets to all of
those shows we added some casinos as
well in the spring we will see you on
patreon and we'll see you in the new
year thank you good night